The star-studded House of Gucci is inspired
by the true story of Italy's infamous Black
Widow who conspired to murder her ex-husband,
but how much of the film is Hollywood fiction
versus historical fact?
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
in this video I'm revealing the biggest things
that House of Gucci got wrong about the real
story of Patrizia Reggiani and the Gucci family.
The true tale of Patrizia Reggiani who came
from humble beginnings and married into the
rich and powerful Guccis has plenty of intrigue
and drama, however, House of Gucci isn't shy
about spicing things up, including Patrizia's
wedding dress.
The movie's costume designer prepared two
designs.
The first was modelled on the real dress worn
by Patrizia which covered her all the way
down to the floor.
But director Ridley Scott opted for an alternate
design that was more revealing and is a homage
to famous Italian actress Gina Lollobrigida.
According to the film's costume cutter,
"even though the [wedding] scene was short,
it was significant for the character, so the
outfit had to have immediacy and impact."
In the movie, Maurizio meets his childhood
friend Paola when he flees to St Moritz to
get away from the Italian tax authorities.
The film plays up the idea that his romance
with Paola began while he was still with Patrizia,
and also that he decided to separate from
his wife while they were together in Switzerland.
In fact though, the details of Maurizio's
split with Patrizia were much different.
It happened one weekend in 1985 when he told
Patrizia he was going on a business trip to
Florence, left with a suitcase and never came
back.
It was left to a friend to tell Patrizia the
next day that it was actually over.
Also, in real life, Maurizio didn't reunite
with Paola until 1990, a full five years after
he left his wife.
On top of that, the movie completely omits
the fact that Maurizio was actually having
an affair with a different woman, Sheree McLaughlin
who said their relationship spurred him on
to leave his unhappy marriage.
Maurizio's affair with McLaughlin lasted until
he met up with Paola years later which did
happen in Switzerland though it was actually
at a club and not on the ski slopes.
I suspect the filmmakers omitted the relationship
with McLaughlin to condense the story given
the final film is already over two and a half
hours long and they chose to portray Paola
over her as that's who he's with at the time
of his death.
Also, having Patrizia share scenes with Paola
ramps up the movie's drama before the separation.
You ever steal anything Paola?
I'm trying to teach Alessandra the importance
of not touching other people's belongings.
The details surrounding how Patrizia would
eventually have Maurizio killed have also
been compressed and dramatized for the movie.
In reality, it appears she didn't meet with
the people involved in the murder as happens
in the film;
instead, she asked lots of different people
if they'd help her, then she got her psychic
friend Pina to act as an intermediary and
find the assassins.
There was also another person involved who
was the real-life getaway driver;
however, in the film his role has been merged
with one of the other conspirators.
Also in the movie, the assassin shoots Maurizio
three times, twice in the back and once in
the chest;
but according to the real-life concierge who
witnessed the murder, the gunman shot Maurizio
a total of four times, three in the back and
a fourth time in his head.
This may have been changed to make it a little
less gory in the movie.
And there's a touch of extra drama in the
trial with Patrizia refusing to answer to
her maiden name Reggiani,
which in reality she also did when signing
her police statement, defiantly telling the
judge to call her Signora Gucci, a reference
to how she continued to use the Gucci name
even after her divorce and how she's popularly
known as Lady Gucci.
And like Lady Gaga or Lady Gucci, if you'd
like your own honorific title, check out Established
Titles, the sponsor of this video.
Established Titles is a project based on a
historic Scottish custom where landowners
are referred to as Lairds
– or Lords and Ladies in English –
and you can buy a piece of dedicated land
in Scotland from as little as one square foot
which allows you to officially call yourself
a Lord or Lady.
So you can have your own Lady Whistledown-style
title in time for the next season of Bridgerton!
And with every order, Established Titles plants
a tree to protect biodiversity in Scotland.
It's a new, fun way to support conservation
and a great surprise gift for your family
and friends
– there are even Couple Title packs available
for partners so you can get adjoining plots
of land.
You'll get an official certificate with a
crest proving your title and a unique plot
number on a private estate in Scotland.
You can use your new title on credit cards,
plane tickets, even dating profiles.
Plus, you'll be helping to preserve woodlands
and raise funds for charities like One Tree
Planted and Trees for the Future who support
global reforestation efforts.
There's some amazing holiday deals on title
packs at the moment, so visit EstablishedTitles.com/Flicks,
and use our special code FLICKS to get an
extra 10% off all purchases, or tap the link
in the video description.
The filmmakers also took some creative license
when staging Maurizio's murder.
The movie's production designer has said that
the spot in Milan on the Via Palestro where
the real murder took place "was drab and uncinematic
and [they] were striving for a more heightened
atmosphere."
So he says they found "a section of Rome with
wide streets that could credibly stand in
for Milan.
And the area was a collage of architectural
styles, Gothic, Renaissance and Arabic [that
gave it] a very operatic feel."
The day that Maurizio was killed, Patrizia
famously wrote in her diary the single word
"paradeisos", which in Greek means "paradise".
In the movie, however, she writes the Italian
version of the word, "paradiso".
I imagine the filmmakers did this as they
thought it seemed more logical and more people
would easily and quickly understand the Italian
word than the Greek one.
The film team also opted for a much more dramatic
way to show how Patrizia had Paola evicted
from the home she'd been sharing with Maurizio.
In the movie, Patrizia turns up at the apartment,
and after embracing Paola tearfully, orders
her to be shown out of what she now calls
her house.
I subscribe to unconventional punishment.
Back in the real world, this never happened.
Instead, the eviction order was delivered
via a notarised letter drawn up around 11am
on the same day Maurizio died, just a few
hours after his death.
Although Patrizia and Maurizio's daughter
Alessandra appears in the film, their second
child Allegra was completely cut from the
story.
I suspect this was done to condense the already-long
movie as even the daughter who does appear
isn't a crucial part of the script.
Also it means the filmmakers could avoid casting
more child actors whose involvement in a production
brings additional rules and regulations, especially
as they'd already had to get three actors
to play Alessandra over a range of ages.
Another interesting detail absent from the
final film is that after Patrizia was convicted,
her daughters tried to get a retrial on the
basis that after their mother had an operation
to remove a brain tumour in 1992, she lacked
proper control over her mental faculties at
the time of the murder.
This did get her sentence reduced by a few
years;
however, since then both daughters seem to
have more or less cut ties with their mother.
When it comes to the look of the characters,
although the movie's make-up and hair team
seem to have done a good job with Patrizia,
the real Gucci family have complained about
some of the cast, claiming their depictions
are unflattering.
One of Maurizio Gucci's cousins has said her
grandfather Aldo was a lot taller than Al
Pacino who plays him and that Pacino's overall
heavier look and sideburns compared unfavourably
to the real-life Aldo who she says was much
more handsome.
Plus, she also felt offended by Jared Leto's
untidy, unfashionable look as Paolo.
Paolo, you are a Gucci.
You need to dress the part.
It's chic.
After the release of the first trailer, some
suggested Lady Gaga's accent was more Eastern
European than Italian.
And since then, Francesca De Martini – an
Italian actress who worked as a dialect coach
for Salma Hayek who plays Pina – commented
that while she was listening to Hayek's scenes,
she thought Gaga's "accent was a bit off",
sounding "more Russian" than Italian.
I don't consider myself to be a particularly
ethical person..
but I am fair.
De Martini also said there were a lot of different
accents in the film with, in her opinion,
Al Pacino sounding "more New York Italian".
Gucci...
is what I say it is.
And Adam Driver's accent being "nearly non-existent".
As far as fakes go, they're pretty good.
At least it's my name on the mugs, not yours.
And then there's Jared Leto's Paolo which
you can make your own mind up about.
These are just mock-ups.
I can't afford to get serious.
You picked a real firecracker.
According to De Martino, there wasn't a dialect
coach on set and she was only brought in at
Hayek's request after the actress felt she
wasn't getting the accent quite right.
Don't let the forces around you dictate who
you are.
You are strong, you are magnificent.
Now, in Lady Gaga's defence, she revealed
in an interview with Vogue that her method
to get into character as Patrizia was very
intense.
She said she "lived as her for a year and
a half [and] spoke with an accent for nine
months of that", apparently never breaking,
even off camera.
If you don't know, I'm gonna make sure you
do.
She also said "it was impossible for [her]
to speak in the accent as a blonde," so she
instantly died her hair.
And she added that she worked hard on figuring
out Patrizia's specific accent.
Bravo.
And uses different ones depending on who she's
talking to in the film.
It's time to take out the trash.
Gaga began with a dialect from Vignola, where
Patrizia was born, and then moved on to what
she described as a "higher class way of speaking
that would have been more appropriate in places
like Milan and Florence".
Whatever you think of the accents though,
all credit [goes] to Lady Gaga for improvising
a line that's already become iconic.
Can you keep a secret?
Father, Son and House of Gucci.
So, what do you think of House of Gucci and
who gave the best and worst performances?
Let me know in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this, then a thumbs-up and
a share are hugely appreciated.
And if you're a fan of crime dramas, tap left
for my latest You video with Season 4 theories
about Love's return or tap right for something
else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!